منذ اكثر من عام شهدت تونس تحولات كبرى
يعني على الصعيد
السياسي انا اتفهم انك كنت بانك لا تريد
ان تتحدث كثيرا في الموضوع السياسي لكن هو
موضوع الساعه سيد عبد الفتاح وانت جل
حياتك تقريبا كانت في اطار هذا العمل
واطار كل التحولات التي شهد المشهد
السياسي في تونس فاعذرني ان اطرح عليك بعض
الاسئله في هذا الشئ يعني قرار حل
البرلمان وضع دستور جديد هناك من وسط ما
يحدث من تغيرات بانها بمثابه احتكار من
الرئيس للسلطات الرئيس التونسي برر هذه
الاجراءات بانها حمايه لتونس وللشعب
التونسي من الغارقين في همم الفساد
اجراءات يعني لتطهير المؤسسات الحكوميه من
الاخوان المسلمين كما يقولوا البعض او
يقراها المراقبون فبالتالي انت كيف تقرا
المشهد اليوم وانت خارج هذه العمليه
السياسيه
كمواطن تونسي
والله انا منذ ان حدثت هذه الاحداث وانا
عايشتها وعاصرتها وكنت اشاهدها واتابعها
الزمت نفسي ان لا اعلق عليها
ان اخرج من هذا الصمت فردا انا استمع الى
مواطني كيف يعلقون ارغب في ان تنتهي هذه
المرحله تنتهي بفاق وطني ما حصل قد حصلت
سواء كان ايجابيا او سلبيا
ليس من دوري ان الشجوبه او اشكر عليه ولكن
انتظروا ان نصل نحن الى خاتمه هذا المسار
بشكل من اشكال التوافق الوطني والا كتب
علينا ان نبقى بعضنا يبني وبعضنا يهدم
والذي يهدم الذي بنى والذي بنى ادم وبذلك
لا يقاموا صرح ابدا
وحوف الاوطان تقام بالتراكم بان يبني بعض
على بناء بعض يغير ما امكن ان يغير لكن
نصل بعد ذلك الى قدره في ان ينظر بعضنا
الى وجه بعض
الان سيد عبد الفتاح
المواطن هل يشعر بان الامور تتجه
هناك دعوه
لا ادري محتواها ولا مالاتها لكن
يسعدني كمواطن يريد ان يعيش في وطن هادئ
يسعدني ان يقع الحديث عن ذلك وان همم
يجتمع عقلاء الوطني ومفكروهم ونخبهم همم
حول
مثال يحتذى من قبل شعوبهم لان الخلاف على
مستوى النخبه ينتقل الى حرابا على مستوى
الشعوب ونحن لا نرغب في انقع في ذلك